that's a lie you have their own
judgmental tattoos and you know my thing
is I Know Who I believe in what I
believe in and I'm not gonna leave Earth
in this form I'm a strong believer in
Christ and I got the genius piece on my
chest I think this one that this will
make me never forget about where I come
from
when I believe in what my family
believes in so these wings
Jesus gave me the strength to spread my
wings and this probably is one of my
favorite ones with Columbus right here
in the skyline and Columbus behind it
you know I got the Clipper saw with it
just because I like that I like their
little logo the boat things like that
after my freshman year in Michigan I got
this time right after the season that
says your past success is the enemy of
your god-given potential you know
meaning you know success could lead to
complacency and that allowed me to work
hard just being able to look at that my
sophomore year and we were the 96 team
in Michigan history I got to him with
him with the yellowing and amazing in
the 96 behind it this right here was my
first tattoo the rose with a LaRhonda on
it which is my mom's name she was she
was she wasn't mad about it because it
was her name but she didn't think it was
gonna be that big so she you know gave
me a little bit proper just 313 pet
blessed the man gains wisdom and
understanding I'm expecting the son in
June so when she gets here I think I get
him up here in this empty area and I
think I'd probably be done after that